I'm going to take the same method I just
used here but we have to be a little
more careful because this graph is just
a little more tricky than the previous
one
okay so thank you we have applied some
of some courses here I'm gonna have a
shift a bit of a stretch what's
happening what you got you said that is
there okay the first thing I'm going to
put on there I have the easiest feature
to recognize is that there's a as an
asymptote in here is a vertical or
horizontal for miss denominator its
vertical okay we'll talk about
horizontal and oblique asymptotes which
are their own classic asymptotes in a
minute but for now recognized but
essentially what you're saying here is
because of the denominator X X which is
a horizontal then are you right X can
never be equal to and and that thing
makes sense okay and X of course is
along here sir if I may to there right
there I'm gonna passenger okay so so far
so good right now
after that I can think about the
horizontal asymptotes which as it
happens is going to be the same okay and
then how is this different from say if
the three wasn't there it was just a 1
what's the do something having a 1 there
and a 3 there it's just going to be able
depeding which when you think about it
it'll be stretched this way or it'll be
squashed this way okay there's a is a
vertical like if I put in values they're
gonna be three times higher than they
would have been if there was just a 1
there okay so when I draw my graph I'm
probably gonna need to have some
intercepts in here to represent because
like you know this shape could just as
well be three of X as it is one X
depending on where I put some values
like if I say that's what there is one
one then I'm on for the next but if I
say it's 1/3 which is perfectly fine
it's a completely different graph down
okay so let's put some intercepts on
here I'm not gonna have any x-intercepts
here but what's my y-intercept going to
be
you come at it how do I get a
y-intercept I say x equals zero x equals
zero so when x equals zero into here I
get three over zero plus 2 which is 3
over 2 one and a half okay so if this is
negative 2 I'll try to keep my scale
reasonably consistent 1 and 1/2 is gonna
be somewhere up there ok I'm not going
quite as far and that's kind of enough
like because over here I'm actually not
gonna cross any intercepts that's going
to be enough to actually draw this thing
like so okay and I'm gonna have the
opposite shape everything ok that's nice
in that case one over there I was
comparing a rational function to
hyper-girl with a horizontal line to but
this time things are more complicated
because I'm comparing with another
linear function okay so what does y
equals x what would that look like on
this graph well we've seen this before
this is just gonna be a line straight
through the origin right so let's go
ahead and draw that you
okay so now we have a look at this thing
what are we after if you have another
color there that will be immensely
helpful if you don't you can try and do
like shading like this I'm looking for
again just like there when one
particular thing is less than or equal
to another thing right so that's the
rational function when is it less than
or equal to my linear function when is
my hyperbola less than or equal to my
straight line so you can look you can
see the points for it are let's go from
left to right okay where is the first
point that you can see the rational
function beneath the linear function
where do we get there
it's there isn't it that's the first
spot where the rational function crosses
over the linear function and goes
underneath okay so I'm just gonna mark
that in right there
that pot satisfies the inequality how
about the boundaries does the boundary
satisfy yeah it does doesn't it because
I have a boundary here and of course if
it was just less than exclusive they
don't have a hollow circle there but I
don't
we'll find out in a second for now I'm
just interested in where are the places
generally speaking where I'm going to
have solutions to this and then I'll
work out the exact values shortly okay
it's worth saying that if the values are
painful to find through one method that
will be painful to find whichever method
you use okay as you'll see in a second
these ones happen to be easy and all
three approaches I'm about to show you
you will find that they are okay because
of the way the functions been crafted
okay now let's keep going here we said
that's the first part okay and keeps
going but it doesn't go on forever does
it it stops at a point there's a point
where after that I'm no longer
satisfying the employee wins a star it's
negative - right - because after that
point right because there's a
discontinuity in the hyperbola things
flip over if I go just to the right of
negative two now I hope Whoville is way
above my linear function okay so I have
to stop there and I have to say well I
can no longer satisfy the employee but
then as I keep going from left to right
it happens again BAM right there
okay sabatons so here I have another
portion of the hyperbola which is good
neat ability okay so there you go
now I have two regions and I just need
to describe them okay so being that
remember this is a 2d illustration to
help us answer a 1d question this is
just an X's that are white I'm now going
to compare this response to the x axis
that's what the real answer is yeah the
x's so I've got this filled circle okay
and then I'm going to go from left to
right until as we just discussed I hit
the asymptote and then what happens
do I have another feeling sir because
I'm inclusive right
why don't I okay
it's an acetone I can't actually get
there right I can get infinitesimally
close but I can't get two negative two
itself okay so that's why this is sort
of a symmetrical thing happening with
this inequality
okay so I'll find out what those values
are in a second
and then of course over here same deal
from this value but this time I do go on
forever okay so now I know what points I
have to describe I just need to find out
their values I already have this one
okay these two values here how am I
gonna find out what they are those two
points right they come from where this
hyperbola intersects with the line right
how do I find points of intersections I
just solved now be careful I don't solve
I don't need to solve simultaneously
right because these things on my diagram
they are simultaneous right
it's just when the hyperbola which is
given by that it is equal to the
straight line which is equal to this I
just have to solve that that's easy
okay now keep in mind because this this
finding the points of intersection it's
just an equation it's just an equation
okay I don't I don't worry about having
to multiply by a square or anything like
that I can just multiply through by X
plus 2 so long as X plus X itself isn't
negative 2 because if I multiply through
by X plus 2 I'll be on in this case
right
all we want to point through my zero
which conduct so anyhow what am I gonna
get x squared plus 2x yeah I multiply 2
by X plus 2 this is very simple once I
bring everything over to one side to
factorize what's the factorization
3x minus 1 that's nice and easy great
block that by the way mark that pair of
factors because they're going to come up
again so now one of my knowledge
negative 3 or 1 now I couldn't have
gotten out a ruler and saw that but you
can see that my graph is at least in the
right ballpark right negative 3 yeah
that does look like that right roughly
and one yeah that's consistent okay so
off of this I can now state my solution
to the inequality right there for this
inequality is satisfied when I'm between
these two values negative 3 inclusive
because I'm diagram Tourister and
exclusive to negative 2 or X is going to
or equal to 1